okay guys it's recording I don't suck in
that we're going to play this game it's
a Tyler Salem it's basically like um I
had on socket now I took the gay mafia
okay if you know what that is
and we're going to troll some people who
are we going to bear today
here we're going to pay and so [ __ ] a
new phone who does okay
oh we're gonna pay shut when we hit the
microphone [ __ ] Tom we're going to be
Matt Damon I'm going to say up by my JV
days hey I need money
okay let's say how do you [ __ ] equip
Scrolls
come on yeah [ __ ] yeah Chester okay my
goal is to be executed perfect this is
the best one this is the best one okay
so you have to try and get people to
hang you thanks to the town trying to
fight the bad people
I am the legend I Matt Damon and I will
win hair fact oh don't kill me at night
now stick ill this is a [ __ ] up I have
to get lynched up please do not kill me
tonight my last will let Ben Affleck now
I love him and his back acne perfect
okay god yes
the other thing I have to figure out
where to put the [ __ ] webcam and I
put in the bottom right just because it
would be anything
rolling for a Roger boy because I heard
he like Coldplay okay
holy [ __ ] better and [ __ ] down
everybody
Roger Voisin as way out bought the
newest album so he hacked to go
[Music]
all right Roger bye
[Music]
oh now random Lynch [ __ ] was a full moon
out tonight that means that Hilary Swank
comes out
hop it up cameraman Jesus
[Music]
okay let's say that's gone on tomorrow
say this is what happens when you repeal
Obamacare
advair [ __ ] [ __ ] Instagram holy
[ __ ] they're pictures of buy my DVDs I'm
going to have to vote against them
you
[Music]
[Music]
[ __ ] eggs six
and we got tap sing
passing you were about to get your pad
zinged ooh we kill them this is just
like that my movies a departed
why is there the gesture will get
revenge from the gray I'm the Jester oh
[ __ ] he's jester his safe has two
jesters [ __ ] up
pleasedon't that blends don't but I've
been here but it's not that [ __ ] these
are two jesters it's [ __ ] up he might
kill me though because I voted against
ur [ __ ] don't die don't die don't die
yes
[Music]
there it is but who is next buy a ticket
stub or get lynched
[Music]
also if you buy a ticket to my pal Ben
Affleck film that works too
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
[Music]
pug is going down
pugs gone down
- Walker puck shut
they know the gesture I'll hold off to
jail thank God at least I won't die
hello I am too rich to be in prison
and I am like what does deal Mike film
sales will skyrocket
holy [ __ ] [ __ ] a they [ __ ] killed
me very sad
Matt Damon not suspect jail corn hope
not suspect lady Bailey and it was Jack
the reparo thought [ __ ] sheriff sheriff
okay
[Music]
they're where I go back I left that up
like though I love it in his back acne
[Music]
my collars type up what the [ __ ] what
the [ __ ] is this kind of like spamming
you [ __ ] you up as we kind of helped
each other out Judds gotta go
[Music]
what about us tell people on gesture
maybe all they say what if I do the
exact same thing when I met Chester well
we [ __ ] them safe
they got a Cal job gun okay time to live
again
okay let's say here let's say here how
do I activate I have a scroll oh okay
wait a clip scroll here we go
so yeah times 10 odds okay we get some
more and we get some more that's girls
together there it's a gesture gesture
scroll
[ __ ] it what is still
[Music]
the [ __ ] psychic scroll bit okay
[Music]
I'd like to buy chair thank you
[Music]
okay cut customization options
[Music]
time story on Ty's time ah [ __ ] okay
wait hold on there's something that I
can where's the [ __ ] help menu
[ __ ] what is Medusa scroll do
okay [ __ ] it
yeah rose
now Jade a 9mm Beretta neighs now if can
avoid money shaming that's a word roll
okay [ __ ] it I always say new phone no
desk that's like what I have to do
I'm Tom Krause today sup normal paper
one ear lots a hodges [ __ ] I don't want
to be [ __ ] investigator this is a
worse one
okay I wanna pretend I'm the Jester
though okay so we gotta forget me nasty
I did Mission Impossible for dearly for
that money
there we go
sake am i hitting this thing like crazy
we're going to tell this that I cut this
[ __ ] microphone socks you're [ __ ]
a lot of [ __ ] right now
oh I skipped well investigate him
okay hi my David a once shave on next
time I David a PI shame on ya
[Music]
come on come on
[ __ ] slow
[Music]
well let's say Harley Quinn is what not
framer oh yeah is the brushroll Sara
werewolf No
[Music]
hey poor doesn't help my movie sales
[Music]
[Music]
okay I base sorry maybe I'll help it's a
palatable hey yes I investigated I skip
in he is bad his movie roles our bed
also see is that in this game the
chiller oh no this is so sad
I'll turn off this music I can't [ __ ]
take it okay
Gazi maybe if you accept it
Scientology you would liked my movies
[Music]
so until I for ice cube because P is
purely picking dope bed films to act in
for money
I say if my mommy
well well okay I'm going to check out a
piece or how can hey I'm a sigh
okay let's say and say what we're gonna
do it let's say what we're going to do
here is a jailer the jailer okay
everybody I got I can tell you now about
it I got you someone occupy what the
[ __ ] you [ __ ] [ __ ]
Sarah good guess Sarah good was too good
to watch my movies huh
I am a famous actor
Who I am in Festa gaiter
[Music]
okay okay baby yeah come touch potatoes
to the touch my tur take hey hey hey
okay other saw about to get you baby
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah
and cat baby yeah baby baby yeah yeah
yeah early [ __ ] I got [ __ ] killed by
the Mafia the [ __ ] well he's done I got
him good
I got hand got top credit okay don't
cross time Christo
to be a domestic violence my my name
just gave you bad is really bad in this
game there we go
okay let's say I still think Paco
because he is pork poor people do crime
okay
okay they're good to go for ice cube
they have to low price Gibbs today not
oh what the [ __ ]
this game is beyond
what the [ __ ]
it suggests at the flock okay
mm-hmm
okay I'm just kind of staying in this
skill want to see what's going on okay
can I just go yeah
I got a poor connect to what Jim no
one's [ __ ] discussing oh [ __ ] okay
they get ice camps
hey stop hey stop
here we go here we go let's go
a TS a dance very sad very sad
okay how you like that I skip
therefore he got to go gotta got Paco I
asked him rich
Mach is going to win dude there's that
way okay I leave in this game
okay I'll sit here let's see yeah let me
see the shop real quick let me say this
shock real quick hi then I was an app
tire
[Music]
at that ask Jackie I guess let me see
repeller
and I guess arsonist
okay heady customers again
[Music]
what's the congratulations okay Erica
[Music]
how are we gonna pay yeah I got away ah
now ahead athle Al Gore
[Music]
[Music]
here we go come on better come on over
just adjuster Jojo sir [ __ ]
[Music]
okay let's say yeah let's see here okay
if we don't want to save the environment
well I'll hash in nature
like a long night 16 seconds what the
[ __ ]
so on roller creams I don't lot Deborah
Deborah
Jonathan no oh no he's [ __ ] scheming
suicide so early like about the cabin
[Music]
and then out by protective armor will
all get lit by climate change boy said
oh ok
the Sun is a world largest hair dryer I
pretend that my knees are meet eyelids -
okay
[Music]
oh my god bunk Claudius he presented his
pecker is not Everest OS sure okay yeah
we go here we go when I get down Lynch
grab my wig on I got that Lynch I sure
hope now that I cast my tonight and now
it I was saying
okay what if we try the old on the
investigator
[ __ ] they got us they got us
and I got us names very sad why is the
[ __ ] music back on
okay she's killed by a member of the
Mafia very sad mother holy medium [ __ ]
now where's that on last night who
stabbed by Sarah [ __ ] hang oh [ __ ]
that [ __ ] sorry I kill the talks first
that's [ __ ] up that is [ __ ] up
let me see it the same thing in
discussion hmm
okay I'll anyway this game let me see we
shipped a better shot executioner soon
color I'll you mafioso let me quip that
world clinic arsonist has to go
[Music]
okay why you keep singing regulations
out on this out that ain't fly solo
okay
once your top games with town of Salem
Ocean I bet Harry and I Bay I'll be back
[Music]
[Music]
okay
yeah [ __ ] gesture again
but yeah just suck a dick you [ __ ]
freak
you [ __ ] for a gank a badass
[Music]
galvez help scenario why are some people
in like brackets
to be honest I know Microsoft zone
[Music]
her pillows on Mac user so he gotta go
[Music]
they're going to get me they're going to
get what is this blue thing like the
music on again [ __ ] music required
Hill chaining games drawings spamming
esker what this [ __ ] his ass guard Dale
holy [ __ ] I went as a [ __ ] portal that
guy spent some serious money in this
game [ __ ] everyone died holy [ __ ]
godbye the holy [ __ ] they got the whole
[ __ ] mafia
and I hang out
rid of all firm they might think I'm the
[ __ ] gesture they'll sell
because of the commercial stuff [ __ ]
okay let's see if they're going to kill
me tonight they might and I've run out
of this size I really know right now
so I just tell them that I'm the Jester
but I somehow now fellas bat here you
rally oh ma in our town
please a lot bang
hahahahaha John the car-rental is chef
CAI
and we [ __ ] won I guess that okay I
guess on this here Dachau